اهلا بكم يسود التوتر مدينه القدس في ظل
اجراءات امنيه اسرائيليه مشدده عقب ردود
فعل فلسطينيه غاضبه اثرها التصعيد
الاسرائيلي المتواصل منذ فتره ضد المسجد
الاقصى
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما طبيعه وابعاد الاحداث التي
تشدها القدس نتيجه الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه
المتواصله للمسجد
الاقصى والى اي حد يمكن ان تتاثر نتيجه
ومسارات هذه الاحداث بتجدد الانقسام
الفلسطيني في هذه
اللحظه في الوقت الذي يواصل فيه اليمين
الاسرائيلي المتطرف وفي القلب منه اعضاء
رئيسيون في الائتلاف اليمني الحاكم
يواصلون استفزازات وانتهاكاتهم ضد المسجد
الاقصى بدا في اسرائيل نوع من الجدل بشان
طبيعه وتكييف مظاهر الغضب الفلسطيني
المختلفه والتي تثيرها وتغذيها هذه
الانتهاكات والاستفزازات فبينما تواصل
سلطات الامنيه تجديد اجراءاتها ضد
المقدسيين تحذر اصوات اخرى من ان المقاربه
الامنيه
لن تحل المشكله وان تواصل استفزازات
اليمين الاسرائيلي يمكن ان يقود في ان
يقود الى انتفاضه فلسطينيه ثالثه ان لم
يكن قد قاد اليها
بالفعل لا يحتاج الامر اكثر من سياره
وقرار عمليه دهس لاسرائيل في يوم واحد
كانت كافيتين لبث الرعب في اسرائيل وهزها
في القلب احتفى الفلسطينيون و جاء احتفائه
مدويا قدر الاحساس بالقهر والعجز
والانتهاك وهم يشاهدون جنود الاحتلال
يدوسون باذت حرم المسجد الاقصى بالنسبه
لاسرائيل تكمن خطوره عمليات كهذه في
بساطتها وبالتالي اصيبت اسرائيل بالذعر
وغرقت في تحليلات انتهت الى ان مواجهه
عمليات من هذا النوع من قبل الشرطه
مستحيله صحيفتها اريتس وصفت ما يجري بانه
انتفاضه مدنيه جامحه منذ الصيف في اشاره
الى العمليات التي لا يستخدم فيها سلاح
وقالت انه بالرغم من ان العمليات التي
تقوم بها الشرطه منعت الى حد بعيد توسع ما
سمته اعمال العنف من الوصول الى المعدلات
التي كانت عليها خلال الانتفاضتين
السابقتين فان الشرطه تفشل في اعاده
المارد الى الزجاجه على حد قول الصحيفه
لكن المارد الفلسطيني لم يدخل الزجاجه حتى
يغادرها ففي انتفاضته سابقه قين واحده عام
887 والثانيه عام 2000 دامت كل منهما نحو
اربع سنوات كان الفلسطينيون يمارسون جميع
انواع المقاومه بينما كانت اسرائيل تواصل
القمع وتجهد في الوقت نفسه كل مسار سياسي
فلم ينتج غير اضاعه الوقت وكرس يقينا لدى
معظم الفلسطينيين بان اسرائيل لا تخشى غير
القوه والمقاومه لا يحجب كل ذلك حقيقه
حدوث تغير كبير في الاوضاع الاقليميه
والفلسطينيه الداخليه مما يجعل التساؤل عن
واقعيه اندلاع انتفاضه ثالثه منطقيا بل
واجبا مما لا شك فيه ان الواقع العربي
تراجع عن مستوى الدعم الخجول الذي قدمه
للفلسطينيين من قبل اما داخليا فلم يعد
الفلسطينيون كتله واحده لا سياسيا ولا
جغرافيا ويبدو ان التقارب الفلسطيني الذي
سمح اخيرا بقيام حكومه وحده وطنيه ما زالت
نظريه الى حد بعيد يواجه الان تحديات كبرى
ليس اخرها مثلا تفجيرات غامضه يصفها
كثيرون بانها مشبوهه استهدفت مقرات لعدد
من مسؤولي حركه فتح في غزه كانت رساله في
وجه الوحده الوطنيه قبل المستهدفين
بالتفجير معنا في هذه الحلقه من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه من غزه صالح
النعامي الكاتب المتخصص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه ومن ت بيب جدعون ليفي الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي في صحيفه هاردز
الاسرائيليه نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا نبدا
بالسيد جدعون
ليفي هناك تقديرات مختلفه الان في الساحه
الاسرائيليه البعض يقول نحن امام بدايات
انتفاضه ثالثه والبعض يقول نحن ربما في
قلب هذه الانتفاضه الثالثه ما هي
التقديرات الاسرائيليه الاكثر رواجا في
اوساط الخبراء
والمحللين حاليا وفي الوقت الحاضر علينا
ننظر الى الوقائع والوقائع هي ان
الانتفاضه محصوره فقط في القدس ولم تنتشر
الى كل الضفه الغربيه او غز غزه ولكن هذا
لا يعني ان الامور لن تخرج عن السيطره
ذلك ان الوضع متفجر الى حد كبير بحيث من
الصعب جدا ان نعرف الى اين ستسير الامور
وال اي مالت اليه فهناك على حدود القدس
يجب ان نذكركم انه خلال ايام حرب غزه ايضا
الناس كانوا يتوقعون حصول انتفاضه اخرى في
الضفه الغربيه ولم يحصل ذلك وبالتالي مثل
الانتفاضات السابقه لم تكن اي انتفاضه
مخططه مسبقا الشروط اللازمه والظروف على
الارض ملائمه والشعور بالاحتجاج موجود ومن
جانب اخر هناك انقسام كبير في صفوف الشارع
الفلسطيني كما تعرفون وما زال
الفلسطينيون تسيل دمائهم من الانتفاضه
السابقه وبالتالي فهل نحن اذاء انتفاضه
جديده ام فقط نمر باوقات عصيبه جدا دكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي فلسطينيا كيف ينظر الى ما
يجري من هذه الزاويه التقديريه ان كانت
الامر انتفاضه او بدايات او مبشرات
بانتفاضه او مؤشرات عفوا لانتفاضه
جديده لا في الواقع نحن نعيش في انتفاضه
ثالثه جديده ولكنها تختلف عن الانتفاضه
الاولى وتختلف عن الانتفاضه الثانيه ومن
هنا هذا التردد في وصفها البعض يقارنها
بالاولى والثانيه والبعض يقارنها بالثانيه
وعندما لا يجد تطابقا ي صل الى استنتاج
مرتبك بانها ربما تكون بدات او ستبدا انما
في الواقع نحن نعيش حاله مقاومه شعبيه
واسعه بدات منذ سنوات ووصلت ذروه كبيره
خلال العدوان على غزه عندما نشبت مظاهرات
في الضفه الغربيه غير مسبوقه من حيث ح
حجمها حتى في الانتفاضه الاولى اليوم مركز
الانتفاضه يقع في مدينه القدس وهذا شيء
طبيعي في التصدي للاحتلال وفي التصدي
للاجرام ولكنها منتشره نحن يوم الجم هذه
الجمعه كان لدينا مظاهرات في قلنديا وفي
كفر قدوم وفي منطقه عوفر والخليل شهدت
مظاهرات ضخمه جدا اذا وبيت لحم وغيرها اذا
نحن لا نتحدث عن انحسار في منطقه القدس بل
بالعكس عن مظاهر مقاومه تجري في كل مكان
وذلك مبني على قناعت اولا قناعه كبرى بفشل
التفاوض وفشل نهج المفاوضات وفشل نهج
اوسلو بالكامل وضروره مقاومه الاحتلال
وثانيا القناعه الثانيه بان اسرائيل لا
تفهم الا لغه القوه وبالتالي لا يمكن ان
يهزم هذا المشروع العنصري وهذا النظام
العنصري الاجرامي الذي راينا مظهر من
مظاهره اليوم في كفر كنا ويمس كل الشعب
الفلسطيني لا يمكن ان يهزم ويوقف الا
بمقاومته وبالتالي هذا تغير كبير في حاله
نوعيه جديده جيل جديد من الشباب الفلسطيني
المقاوم ينضم الى هذه الساحه جيل لم يعرف
الياس ولا الاحباط وهو غير مثقل باعباء
الديون والمشاكل التي اشرت بعد اذنك دكتور
الى نقطه مهمه جدا وهو ان نعم اشرت الى ان
مركز الاحداث الان في القدس وربما هذا سيد
صالح
نعامي ما يعطي هذه الاحداث خصوصيه معينه
هذه المره رغم وجود تحركات في اماكن اخرى
هل تعتقد بان هذه الشراره الدينيه
المتمثله في الحرم وفي الاقصى اعطت
التحركات الفلسطينيه هذه المره ابعاد ربما
لم تكن متوفره بشكل قوي في المرات السابقه
بالطبع اذا استثنينا ان انتفاضه سنه 2000
بدات اصلا بزياره اريال شارون الى الحرم
القدسي يا سيده هذا ما يحدث بالضبط عندما
يخرج وزير اسرائيلي بارز وهو وزير الاسكان
اوريا ارائيل بعدما قام رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنمي نتنو بطمان ملك الاردن
بانه اسرائيل لن تغير الوضع القائم في في
المسجد الاقصى يخرج علينا ويعلن بالتزام
اسرائيل بتدشين الهيكل طبعا تدشين الهيكل
على انقاذ المسجد الاقصى عندما يكون من
اصل 21 نائب من يمثلون حزب الليكود الحاكم
الذي يراسه بنيمين الثنيا 17 نائب يؤيدون
تغيير الوضع القائم في القدس تغيير الوضع
القائم فقط للتذكير يعني تقاسم التقاسم
الزماني ما بين اليهود والمسلمين في داخل
المسجد الاقصى نقل الاشراف من على الاقصى
من دائره الاوقاف الاسلاميه الى وزاره
الادي الديان الاسرائيليه
وحتى وصولا الى التقاسم المكاني عندما
عندما يتعهد ثاني اهم وزير في اسرائيل وهو
نفت البنت الذي تتوقع استطلاعات الرائي في
اسرائيل ان حزب البيت اليهودي سيكون ثاني
اكبر حزب بعد الانتخابات القادمه يتعهد
بان يكون تغيير الوضع القائم في المسجد
الاقصى سيكون على راس اولويات او في راس
ال ويات الحكومه القادمه التي يتوقع على
نطاق واسع ان يكون ان يلعب دورا مركزيا
فيها كل هذا لا يدع مجالا للشك بانه نحن
اسرائيل هي التي اشعلت الحرب الدينيه
وبالمناسبه عن عند الحديث عن توقع هل تكون
انتفاضه ثالثه او لا تكون المساله ليست
مساله خيار بالنسبه للشعب الفلسطيني هذا
الامر يتم فرضه على الشعب الفلسطيني بسبب
السياسات المجنونه ل للحكومه الاسرائيليه
وبالمناسبه الامر لا يدور عن يمين متطرب
نحن نتحدث الان كل سطعات الراي في اسرائيل
تقول انه اي انتخابات قادمه اليمين كتل
اليمين و اكثر من 74 مقعد من اصل 120 مقعد
ممكن ان تاخذ وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن حلبه
سياسيه موغله في التطرف لا نتحدث عن تطرف
بل عن جنون تطرف يكسح الساح اسرا هذا ماين
نعم هناك ايضا نقطه سيد نعامي اسال عنها
السيد جدعون ليفي بعض المحللين
الاسرائيليين يشيرون الى ان ال الامر
المختلف في القدس ان من يتعامل مع جمهور
المتظاهرين هم قوى الامن وليس الجيش مثل
ما هو حادث في الضفه الغربيه وبالتالي
فمستوى القمع كما يقولون ليس بمستوى ما
يمارسه الجيش الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه
وان هذا ربما ربما يجعل من امكانيه الرد
الفلسطيني ليس بالقوه التي كان في
انتفاضات سابقه هل هذا هل هذه النقطه مهمه
يجب اخذها بعين
الاعتبار
كلا ليس حقا لان الاحتلال قاسي ووحشي في
كل مكان فهو قاسي ووحشي بطبيعته و وصحيح
انه في القدس الشرقيه الشرطه اكثر حذرا
مما عليه قوات الجيش في غزه او في الضفه
الغربيه ولكن في نهايه المطاف
تشاهدون ان الاحتلال
ووحشي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ينطبق عليه هذا
الوصف فاذا كان سكان القدس الشرقيه يعيشون
تحت نفس الوحشيه والقسوه كما هو حال بقيه
الفلسطينيين وبالتالي فان هذا لن يقلل من
مستوى احتجاجاتهم
ومقاومتهم وفي الوقت ذاته لابد من القول
انه في القدس الشرقيه نسمع المزيده
والمزيد من الاصوات الاسرائيليه التي تدعو
الى المزيد من العنف ضد المقاومه وحتى
ارسال الجيش الى القدس الشرقيه طبعا ان
اسرائيل لن تقوم بقصف القدس الشرقيه من
الجو كما فعلت في
غزه ولكن هناك وسائل اخرى
كافيه يمكن ان تتعرض لها القدس الشرقيه
فتلته فيها النيران كما هو حال المناطق
الاخرى تحت الاحتلال ولكن سيد ليفي بحكم
ما اقدمت عليه اسرائيل طوال السنوات
الماضيه من تفكيك
لاوصيك
عنصر مانع لاندلاع انتفاضه تكون قويه
ومتماسكه هي الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه ليس
فقط الفصل بين القدس الشرقيه والضفه
الغربيه بل فوق كل ذلك والاهم من
ذلك العزل القاتل بين غزه والضفه الغربيه
وبين فلسطينيه 48 في اسرائيل والفلسطينيه
الضفه الغربيه
وغزه هذه اسلوب او طريقه قديمه جدا
يستخدمها المحتلون لفرض سيطرتهم وان
اسرائيل تطبق هذه الطريقه هنا ايضا ولكن
في نهايه المطاف الاحتلال هو احتلال وان
اي احتلال هو في
تاريخه خلق المقاومه ادى الى مقاومه وليس
هناك اي احتلال في التاريخ استمر الى
الابد وبالتالي المساله تتعلق بالوسائل
وفتره الزمنيه ولكن في النهايه نحن
نتعامل مع
احتلال احتلال يؤدي الى خلق المقاومه كما
هو حوال كل الامثله في التاريخ حول ذلك
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد سدون ليفيا الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي في صحيفه اردز
الاسرائيليه صاحبتنا في هذا الجزء الاول
من البرنامج شكرا جزيلا لك بينما الجزء
الثاني سنناقش فيه مع ضيفين ان كان هناك
تاثير لما يمكن وصفه بتجدد الانقسام
الفلسطيني على الاقل في هذه اللحظه على
الاحداث الجاريه حاليا في القدس لنا عوده
بعد الفاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها ابعاد الاحداث
التي تشهدها القدس واثر تجدد الخلاف
الفلسطيني في هذه اللحظه على مسارها
كاحتمال
قائم دكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي ما جرى مؤخرا في غزه وعوده نوع
من الانقسام او على الاقل نقول عوده نوع
من التلاسن بين فتح وحماس هل تعتقد بان
هذا يمكن ان يؤثر الان على وتيره الغضب
الشعبيه والاحتجاجات في في القدس
وغيرها لا يجب ان يؤثر ودعني اوضح هنا قبل
ان اجيب على سؤالك نقطه مهمه تتعلق بما
تقوم به اسرائيل اسرائيل تقوم بعمليتين
متناقضتين من ناحيه هي تجزئ الشعب
الفلسطيني بالحواجز بالتنكيل بمنع التنقل
ولكن من ناحيه اخرى تعيد توحيد الشعب
الفلسطيني بحكم انه كله ستهدف اليوم الذي
جرى في كفر كنا دليل على ذلك جرائم وحشيه
ضد الفلسطينيين سواء في داخل اراضي ال 48
او في القدس او في الضفه الغربيه استيطان
مستفحل في كل مكان قمع وتنكيل في كل مكان
دمار اقتصادي حصار اجرامي على غزه جرائم
ارتكبت ضد النساء والاطفال اليوم انا
برايي يحدث اعاده انصهار للشعب الفلسطيني
وخاصه في الشتات الذين همشوا عن القضيه
الفلسطينيه على مدار سنوات طويله بعد
اوسلو يعود الان الى الساحه عبر حركه
المقاطعه وفرض العقوبات انا برايي يولد او
تولد مرحله جديده من النضال الفلسطيني
عنوانها الرئيسي المقاومه والكفاح لكسر
هذا المشروع الاسرائيلي وهذا المشروع
العنصري الصهيوني من ناحيه ثانيه طبعا
الانقسام الداخلي يؤذينا جدا وما جرى في
غزه مؤسف ومدان ومرفوض بكل المعايير وانا
ادعو الى الاسراع في الكشف عن المجرمين
الذين ارتكبوا هذهه الامور لانها لا تفيد
الا اعداء الشعب الفلسطيني ويجب الكشف عن
تلك الاصابع والايدي التي تساعد على تخريب
الاوضاع حتى تشغل الشعب الفلسطيني عن
معركته الرئيسيه ضد الاحتلال ومع ذلك اقول
ان الانقسام يدور على ماذا الصراع الداخلي
يدور على سلطه وهميه كلها تحت الاحتلال
نعم ول ولكن اشرت ولكن عف اشرت الى نقطه
مهمه الذي يجري في الضفه الغربيه بعد اذنك
دكتور اشرت الى نقطه مهمه وهو ان ما يجري
بالعكس اعاد توحيد الشعب الفلسطيني وهنا
نسال سيد صالح العامي عما اذا كانت
المرحله الحاليه تجاوز فيها الفلسطينيون
الغاضبون
والمقموع اي تصنيف فصائلي فتح او حماس او
غيرها اصبح القمع حاد بدرجه لم يعد فيها
المواطن الفلسطيني يقيم وزنا لتلويث وانما
للون وطني ولضرورة
المقدس المقدسيين القمع يشمل ايضا الخليل
اهالي الخليل الذي يحضر عليهم في بعض
الاحيان الانتقال من شارع الى شارع ومن من
حي الى اخر القمع يشمل ما يتعرض له
الفلسطينيون في شمال الضفه الغربيه الذين
يترك المستوطنين لكي يقوم باطلاق قطعان من
الخنازير لاتلاف مزارعهم لكن على كل
الاحوال هناك يجب ان انلا يتم تسويف
الامور يعني للاسف الشديد في الوقت الذي
اي ا تقوم اسرائيل بكل جرائمها في في
القدس وفي غزه وفي مناطق شتى في الضفه
الغربيه كان يفترض ان يكون هناك تحرك
فلسطيني رسمي جاد ضد اسرائيل وهناك حديث
عن انه ال الجانب الفلسطيني والسلطه
الفلسطينيه ان تتوجه الى الامم المتحده
لرفع قضايا ضد اسرائيل لكن للاسف الشديد
نسمع تهديدات ونسمع وعود ولكن لا نسمع
تطبيقا على الارض في الوقت الذي يقمع
الفلسطينيون في القدس ايضا يقمع
الفلسطينيون الذين يتظاهرون في نابلس وفي
الخليل انتصارا للقدس وبالتالي هناك يجب
ان توضع الامور على نصابها ان يسال السؤال
الاكبر وهذا هذا حق الشعب الفلسطيني على
القيادات
الفلسطينيه ما هي خيارات هذه القيادات وما
هي اولوياتها نحن هناك في حاجه ماسه لكي
يتم تحديد بوصله هذا الشعب وبوصله قيادته
منذ اكثر من سنه ونص او سنتين واذكر انه
في اجتماع كان حضره الدكتور مصطفى الب
البرغوثي توعد في الرئيس ابو مازن بان يتم
الانضمام
لكل المحافل الدوليه لتعقب اسرائيل ولكن
حتى هذه اللحظه لم لم نرى
عملا على الارض هذا هذا ما يتوجب هذا
التحدي الذي يفرض على القياده الفلسطينيه
كما يفرض على بقيه مركبات الشعب الفلسطيني
وما حدث في غزه يعني هو حدث خطير استهداف
منازل قيادات حركه فتح يتوجب الكشف عن
الجناه لانه لا يحتمل الشعب الفلسطيني
فتح ونك مزيد من الجراح في الوقت الذي
تستبيح فيه اسرائيل كلكل الفلسطيني هناك
ايضا نقطه اخرى مهمه اشار اليها بعض
الكتاب والمحللين ونريد ان نسال عنها كل
من الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي والسيد صالح
النعام هناك من يشير الان الى ما هو اخطر
من الانقسام بين الفلسطينيين ان هناك طوال
السنوات وطوال
استمرار التسويه والممارسات الاسرائيليه
برزت نوع من العقليه الفرديه ونوع من ما
سماها البعض تراجع القدره على التعبئه
وتفاقم اشكال المساوات اللام مساواه
الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه وان هذا ربما
سيكون محبط للفلسطينيين لقيامهم باي تحرك
ناجع هل فعلا هذه النقطه جديره بالاهتمام
والدراسه الدكتور
برغوثي طبعا جديره ولكن هذه النقطه تتعلق
بفئه صغيره محدوده انا اسميها فئه مستفيده
من حاله البقاء تحت الحاله الحاليه وهي
فئه فعلا صغيره ومعزوله عن الشعب
الفلسطيني وهي التي تخشى الانتفاضه اكثر
من اي طرف اخر لانها لا تريد ان يتغير
الحال لكن غالبيه الشعب الفلسطيني مختلفه
غالبيه الشعب الفلسطيني تريد ان ترى كفاحا
فعالا ومؤثرا واذا سمح لي ان اقول ربما
اقول ان الشعب الفلسطيني متقدم على
قياداته حتى الشعب الفلسطيني منذ منذ
سنوات يطالب بقياده وطنيه موحده قياده
وطنيه موحده من شانها ان تجعل النضال مؤثر
وفعال اكثر وقياده وطنيه موحده من شانها
ان تغلق الابواب امام محاولات العبث
بالساحه الداخليه واحداث انقسام عميق
الخلاف والانقسام يدور على سلطه وهميه لا
وجود لها كلها تحت الاحتلال وهي نتاج
تجربه اوسلو نحن بحاجه الى وحده في حركه
التحرر الوطني وما تراه الان من اختلاف في
الاجتهادات هو انعكاس ل تفاوت ما بين
مرحله سابقه انتهت برايي ومرحله قادمه
مختلفه ولذلك ليس غريبا ان يكون جيل
الشباب هو الاكثر انضواء في المقاومه
واكثر مطالبه بها واكثر رغبه في الكفاح
الوطني من اجل كرامته وحريته واستقلاله
دكتور نعامي سيد نعامي
تفضل ي نعم يعني هناك كما يصنف المؤرخون
فتره الفاصله ما بين 1982 ل
1987 كانت اكثر الفترات التي قتلت فيها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ولكن في
1987 عندما طغى الممارسات الاسرائيليه
العدوانيه فجر الشعب الفلسطيني
انتفاضته انتفاضته المباركه الاولى
وبالتالي هذا هذا ان دل على شيء فانما
يدلل على حقيقه يعني تكررها دائما تكرسها
التجربه التاريخيه بانه الشعب الفلسطيني
لا يمكن ان يسمح بفراغ تستفيد منه اسرائيل
وهو وهو بذلك قدم على قياداته وما يحدث
بالمناسبه في القدس من عمليات فرديه هذه
العمليات الفرديه التي تشكل تحدي كبيرا
لاجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه هو هو رساله
للقيادات الاسرائيليه بانه اذا حاولت
اسرائيل تغيير الوضع القائم وتغيير اصول
القواعد المواجهه في القدس فان الشعب
الفلسطيني بقوا بقوا الحيه
وبدون دعم الفصائل وبدون توجيهاتها
بامكانه ان يعيد خلط الاوراق بشكل لا
تتصوروا اسرائيل ولا يمكن ان تقف امامه
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد صالح النعامي الكاتب
المتخصص في شؤون الاسرائيليه شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من رام الله الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد
وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد غدا باذن الله
دمتم في رعايه الله والى
اللقاء
ان